hi there steve goffin here in palm
springs
um
i decided to try filming outside because
i had some negative comments
about the redness of my eyes using the
lights inside
um
i'm going to talk about space repetition
systems which are very popular amongst
language learners i'm going to give you
my perspective on them and why i don't
use them a lot
um
down here in palm springs i've been here
for about 12 days enjoying it it's very
warm it's sunny
we're having renovations done on our
house in vancouver
which is a good reason to be down here
also we were able to get our second
vaccine dose the pfizer
and we appreciate that and uh minor
excitement like a bat flew in the house
a couple of nights ago and
uh following we were closing into one
room and the next morning phoned the
wildlife
uh who came within 40 minutes and took
it away very impressed with the level of
service
um
now
space repetition now remember that to me
and i think
this is
sort of beyond dispute the most
important elements in language learning
are
your attitude in other words are you
enjoying it
and second of all
are you putting in the time those are
the overwhelming issues
so
obviously if you enjoy doing space
repetition systems then you should do
them
even if they are a less efficient way of
spending your time than something else
if it increases the amount of time you
spend with the language then they are
good things to do
spaced repetition systems uh represented
by
well-known names
especially for language learning like
anki a-n-k-i and memorize and others are
widely used by language learners
the idea is that there is an ideal sort
of spacing
uh between when you first encounter a
new
bit of information to learn like a word
and when you should next meet that and
then next and the next and next again
and so typically in space repetition
systems there are flash cards
and you schedule these new words or
phrases to appear at a certain interval
which the app
will you know schedule for you in a way
that optimizes your ability to retain
these bits of information
so there's nothing wrong with doing that
so why am i not a fan and i should point
out too that at link we also use space
repetition systems and we have flash
cards
but to me
the use of flashcards based repetition
systems etc
is
the advantage of it is that it's a
randomized way to expose you to the
language a different way than let's say
reading or listening so it's another way
to get at the same bits of information
i am not persuaded that the sort of
optimized algorithm achieves a great
deal
um because
you know it's not like you're learning
objective facts of history which there
might be
five thousand that you need to learn or
one thousand or some such number
when we're dealing with words we're
dealing
with a situation where the frequency
with which these words appear in text
declines very very rapidly so that
the most frequent 500 words you're going
to see them so often that you almost
needn't worry about learning them
but that's when the space repetition
system is going to be the most effective
and i certainly use spaced repetition
for learning chinese characters because
i decided that the first thousand
characters
which would be very important for me to
build up my vocabulary beyond that
that i would use this sort of
concentrated
way of getting at them and each one with
all of the different strokes and stuff
like that i felt it would be a useful
thing to do
also when i was learning chinese i had
six seven eight ten hours a day however
much time i wanted to spend
it was my full-time job so i would still
have three hours of one-on-one uh
lessons with my two teacher i would
still be reading a lot i would be
listening a lot and i would put in an
hour or so a day with these
thousand highest frequency characters
using
sort of a self-designed spaced
repetition system
however since that time i have never
used space repetition systems whenever i
find myself going through a long list
and and remember that
in the languages that i have learned at
link
the number of sort of words that i have
saved
links that i have created numbers in the
tens of thousand
okay uh
in a way
the way i create flash cards at link
every time i save a worded link i've
created a fresh card flash card every
time i save a phrase i've created a
flashcard
and i do review these when i turn the
page
when i have just read a page and there's
a bunch of words there that
either i just saved or i've saved
previously and they've shown up
again and to kind of refresh them a
little bit to hit me again with them
i'll review them as i turn the page
but i will not sit down
for a list of
you know five thousand ten thousand
words that i have saved in other words
flash cards that i have remembered or in
anki terms a deck
that i've created simply by reading and
listening on link and saving words and
phrases i've got a deck i've got lots of
them
um i can even uh on link if i tag them
you know i can tag them for verbs i can
tag them for tag them for other parts of
speech i can
i can look at only the ones that
i i just met or the ones that i almost
know and and i've experimented with all
of these different ways of of going
through these words in some kind of a
concentrated learning session and i
always find that i lose interest so i do
it sporadically but obviously if you're
doing it sporadically you're defeating
the purpose of this based repetition
system because the space repetition
system assumes that there's a certain
regularity okay now because of the
way in which frequency declines so
quickly
the first 500 the first thousand
fine you can see them again in your
space repetition review
you'll probably also come across them in
some form of space repetition
just through the natural process of
listening and reading but after that the
frequency declines so quickly
that so many of the words that you need
to learn they're only going to show up
i don't know twice in a book
some of them and yet you still need to
know them so even if you learn them
through some kind of space repetition
you're likely to forget them again
and to try to maintain all
20 000 of them in some kind of a deck
that you're constantly reviewing
would start to monopolize all your study
time
so
i just but i repeat what i said at the
beginning people who enjoy doing that
should do it i don't ever when i'm doing
flashcards and i do them from time to
time as i say when i'm turning the page
i never treat them as a sort of a test
of my memory i'll try to remember i just
treat them as exposure in fact i'll put
everything on the face of the flashcard
i just flip through them as quickly as i
can one thing that's good about
our flashcards or activities at link
is that we have a variety of different
activities that come at you in a
randomized way so again by randomizing
the nature of the activity in other
words it's either a flash card or a
reverse flash card or dictation or a
closed test or multiple choice so that
makes it a little more interesting
but i always come away if i ever do sit
down for 30 minutes and just to go
through a deck of saved words and
phrases i really wonder if i achieved
anything
and of course if i don't do it regularly
i won't have achieved anything but the
idea of spending half an hour a day when
i only have an hour to spend on language
learning to spend that time on flash
cards is not something that i'm prepared
to do the
biggest part of my learning time is
simply listening there is another issue
with flash guards and i'm not a
neuroscientist but
manfred spitzer whom i often quote he is
a
neuroscientist and he says that the
brain has trouble learning details we
forget details they're in our
hippocampus we lose them we forget them
what the brain is best at doing
is creating patterns recognizing
patterns creating links
and that way becoming familiar with
everything that we encounter in life
that's what the brain does it it it
enables us to deal with situations by
creating patterns so that we start to
recognize what's about to happen and
that's how we become familiar with a
language and my impression is that if i
can listen and read to content of
interest
without worrying too much about what i
forget and what i remember
gradually over time my brain is going to
become familiar with the language and
that that is a more effective and in my
case more enjoyable way of learning than
trying to go through these stacks of
flashcards
so
and you know a big problem i think in in
anki for many people is even creating
these decks
at least at link
this job is done for you because when
you're reading and saving words you're
adding uh items words or phrases to the
deck that you're going to review but i
still think that once you're
you know the number of words that you
have saved the links that you have
created starts to get over ten thousand
um
i don't know how you can continue
doing justice to the the principles of
these uh you know the algorithms of
space repetition
and at the same time
find time to do the listening and
reading and speaking that you also need
to do
and
so
there you have it
i use uh
you know
add link i arbitrarily decide that a
certain word is no longer status one
it's now status two i know it a little
better status three i know it even
better status four i know it then i move
it back again because words that i
thought i really knew all of a sudden i
don't know them it always bounces back
and forth uh that's how i study but i
want to stress again that that the two
key elements to success and language
learning are
one
keeping a positive attitude enjoying
what you're doing
and second of all
you know finding the time to do it and
so if you are a devotee of space
repetition you enjoy doing it that's
what you find the time to do by all
means keep doing it i'm not suggesting
people should stop i'm just explaining
why i'm not a big fan or a big user
there you have it and here are a couple
of videos that you might find relevant
to this whole issue of remembering and
words and how we learn languages
bye for now